This is why participants should be randomly assigned to treatment, meaning
everyone has an equal chance of being assigned to either of the two treatments.
In theory, randomization makes the two groups similar. On average, for example,
the groups should be similar in age, the number of males and females, their
sleep habits, et cetera. And that's why it's good to have a big sample size.
Randomization works best with larger groups. We'll come back to the benefits of
larger samples later in this class. Now one more thing before we end this story.
We started this module with the question, If you're preparing for your exam
tomorrow, should you stay up studying or should you go to sleep? Researchers
have demonstrated using both observational and experimental studies, that sleep
is important for memory. Getting a good night's sleep will likely pay off more
than a couple of extra hours of studying. On the right you'll find a link to an
interesting story, of you'd like to learn more about this topic. I wish I had
have known that in college.